welcome welcome welcome into Market
takes man you know it's my favorite day
of the month 10 times a year we get to
do this we get to sit around here and
chop up what just happened at the fomc
meeting I am Dion raoan reporter at the
Wall Street Journal and we are breaking
down examining unpacking opening up
everything that happened at the FED
meeting we're going to be talking about
the fomc statement we're going to be
talking about what fed share Jerome
Powell said we're going to be talking
about how the market reacted we are
going to get into to all of that right
here on Market takes I know you could
have been anywhere in the world but
you're here with me and I appreciate
that listen today we're going to talk
about what the fed's decision was like I
said break down that statement and the
press conference we're going to talk
about chair Pal's remarks we're going to
talk about how the markets reacted very
interesting Market reactions today I'm
excited to get into that of course we're
going to talk about the big picture
takeaway and we are going to talk about
what comes next because as you know here
on Market takes we are always looking
forward even though it is backward
looking data although today with the fed
this is all about what comes in it's all
about what's happening in March so
listen let's get into it first thing I
want to do here is throw up on your
screen a chart of the FED funds rate so
you can see just where we are
historically now the FED kept rates
unchanged at this meeting between 5.25
and 5.5% again this is the highest rates
have been in about 22 years you see
where we are now that's on the right
hand side of your screen that's higher
than we've been any time going all the
way back to 2001 we were in that
recession or going into that recession
um going on 23 years but really this
chart just illustrating how high the FED
funds rate has gone and now that we're
at that high level it looks like we're
kind of starting to taper and what folks
in the market had been expecting was
this meeting was going to be the meeting
that sets up rate Cuts so for those
rates to start coming down for that line
to start moving lower well Fair chair
Fed chair Jerome pal said hold on wait a
minute let me talk to you and it started
with the statement so want to do
something a little new here let's throw
up the statement on your screen so you
can take a look at it and I wanted to
highlight I've got highlighted here a
couple of the most important changes
these things were not in the statement
uh in December and they were added this
time the committee judges at the risk to
achieving its unemployment and inflation
goals are moving into better balance oh
that's nice the economic Outlook is
uncertain and the committee remains
highly attentive to inflation risks that
was an ad but the biggest ad here the
thing that really set the table for what
was to come during this press conference
and why we got the market action that we
did was this sentence right here the
committee does not expect does not
expect it will be appropriate to reduce
the target range until it has gained
greater confidence that inflation is
moving sustainably toward
2% does not expect so here's why that
matters a lot of what's been baked into
Market markets a lot of that bullishness
a lot of the 25% gain we saw for the S&P
500 last year a lot of the big start to
2024 that we saw that was baked in the
Fed was going to be cutting rates and
What markets had predicted was that the
Fed was going to start cutting rates as
soon as March that's its next meeting so
to do that well the FED can't just come
out and surprise the markets haha
surprise rate cut no the fed's going to
start setting things up it's going to
start setting the table they're going to
start with their policy uh meeting
they're going to start with their
Communications they're going to start in
their media appearances we talked to
former St Louis fed president uh James
Bullard a couple months ago on the
podcast we tal or sorry a couple months
a couple weeks ago um we talked to F San
Francisco fed president Mary daily we
talked Chicago fed president uh Austin
gouby and when they come out and they
speak with media and they do those
things they kind of start to set the
table say hey here's what could be
coming be on the lookout we're thinking
about this we're not making any
decisions yet but here's here what we're
thinking about this statement right here
makes it clear we are not cutting rates
in March and they're not going to say
they're not going to say absolutely
because the FED doesn't want to be boxed
in the FED doesn't want to say they're
going to do something and then things
change economic data change the market
changes and now they can't do what they
said they want to get the market set up
by dropping little hints and this hint
right here does not expect it will be
appropriate to reduce the target range
until it gained until it has gained
greater confidence that inflation is
moving sustainably toward 2% that
sustainably word fed chare pal
highlighted again and again in his press
conference we'll get into that in just a
minute also important to note in that
statement what was removed they removed
all references to the quote sound and
resilient banking system of the United
States that was interesting they had
thrown that in there in case folks were
getting a little worried about the
banking system they had said in their
past in their past statement the the you
know the banking system is fine it's
sounding resilient we think everything's
great that's out of there could be read
as a sign that they don't think they
need to talk about it anymore that it's
not something they feel they need to
really convince the public of that that
doesn't need to be in the statement
again you can read that any way you want
but that was also removed from the
statement um additional policy firming
that language was removed so that was
why you saw maybe some moves from the
market where at first it was like oh
okay well maybe this is a dovish hike
which you know is generally going to
push risk assets like stocks up push
bond prices up meaning push yields down
that's what you saw there but then as
you get into the statement you read that
statement I read to you or that sentence
I read to you and that sort of change
things interestingly enough the FED fund
Futures Market was actually pricing in a
higher chance of a cut by March as soon
as this statement came out by the time
Fed chair pow finished with his press
conference that had been wiped out the
likelihood of a March cut is almost all
the way off the table investors are no
longer betting on that so the press
conference really I think the table was
set by the statement but the press
conference if there was any doubt in
anyone's mind about what the Fed was
trying to communicate investors got the
message and the message was these rate
Cuts ain't coming in March get ready for
may we want to cut rates we're getting
ready to cut rates we're gearing up to
cut rates it's probably coming it's
probably coming but but not in March so
cool it that was kind of what we got
from this statement and what we got from
Fed chair Jerome pal at the press
conference basically the big picture of
chair Pal's press conference as we step
back here and watch the whole thing
right here in the studio uh Fed chair
the chairman and the committee feel good
about the economy they just want to see
more we've seen inflation coming down
we've seen jobs holding up we've seen
these things that we need to look at
that are moving in the direction we want
to see we just need to see more and that
was really the message that fed share
drow was trying to communicate through
every question he answered from the
media today in fact he was even tapping
his pen I don't think I've ever seen the
chairman tap in his pen when he's making
it when he's making a point he was he
was kind of listen let me tell you
what's going on the committee intends to
move carefully data dependent meeting by
meeting and he said this was very
interesting based on the meeting today I
would tell you that I don't think it's
likely the committee will have the
confidence to and this this is my words
not his but to cut rates in March he he
phrased it more delicately in a way that
no one would really understand but what
he was saying was the committee doesn't
have the confidence right now to set up
that rate cut for March you can go back
you can check the tape find out exactly
what he said but more or less what he
was saying was we don't have the
confidence to cut in March and he went
on to say that's probably not the most
likely instance again those rate Cuts in
March which the market had been pricing
in so when we talk about markets here in
just a minute you are going to see the
reaction to Fed chare pow's press
conference and to that statement from
the FED um that actually when he was
responding was in reference to a sorry
actually I'm talking about the wrong
thing the other really strong Market
reaction was to Fed share pal saying
that he doesn't think the market has
achieved the soft Landing he said quote
I wouldn't say we've achieved that
referring to the soft Landing certainly
we're encouraged by the progress but
we're not declaring victory at this
point we think we've got a ways to go
ways to go means rates stay high you
don't get those rate Cuts rates continue
to hold up through March likely through
at least May which is what investors are
now pricing in but that was the big
takeaway here we are unlikely to get
those cuts in March based on the data
that we have so far based on the
information that the FED has received
and based on what's going on in the
markets it's looking like based on what
fed chare pal and his colleagues
discussed based on what he told us at
this press conference we are not getting
a rate cut for March and that changes
the thesis in the markets in a
significant way um let's talk about
really quick let's get to the markets I
want to throw up here on the market I've
been talking about what's going on I
want to see I want you guys to see what
I'm talking about look at the Dow down
82% today but you see where the market
kind of went up okay the statement came
out right around 2 o'clock that's right
around here right Market said oh okay
this this could be nice maybe maybe
those rate cuts are coming and then boom
nope no rate cuts and we get this
selloff where the Dow is down 82% let's
look at the NASDAQ down about two and a
half or
2.25% similar thing statement comes out
right around 2 o'cl Market gets a little
excited okay maybe there's some good
stuff in here maybe we get those rate
Cuts up no we not getting those rate cut
cuts and you see the stock market just
sell off investors were pricing in
pretty heavily those rate cuts and you
see a similar reaction when you're
looking in the bond market now what
we've really seen and what's been really
interesting is the way that bonds have
now moved back down especially this
two-year note right you saw a lot of
movement during the press conference
this is the press conference right here
you're seeing bond yields go up go down
that's investors this two-year note is
very tied to what investors think is
going to happen with fed policy and you
see it going up basically up means they
think that rates are going to stay high
down means that rates could come back
down and that's what you see you see
that push and pull based on what fed
share pal said and what you see
ultimately here as we get close to
Market close is the market saying all
right we don't think that rate cut is
coming in March and in fact maybe we're
not going to get as many rate Cuts this
year when you look at at the FED funds
Futures Market you are seeing now a
repricing the market had been expecting
six rate cuts from the fed this year now
pricing in only only five so that's
pretty significant and now you've got to
kind of repic all your assets so as you
look here the most significant move was
in the three-year note that's kind of
between fed policy and the overall
economy uh but as you get out here to
the 30-year Bond that's where you see
the least uh the least amount of yield
change that's only about seven basis
points on the yield one other thing I
thought was really interesting you
didn't see a big reaction from a lot of
markets but you did see it here in the
currency Market you see in the Euro
there again right around around that
2:00 time selloff and that's the Euro
against the dollar so as the Euro's
falling right here you're seeing the
dollar gaining you see it here in the US
dollar Index the dollar moving in the
opposite direction right around that 2
o'cl time frame when investors really
priced in the pow speech and what he was
saying at that press conference you see
the dollar picking up and Rising pretty
strongly uh cryptocurrency along with
the market I think this is really just a
risk asset story but usually crypto not
that moved by what happens in terms of
fed policy and on the markets well we
see it again right around here at 2:00
you see just this selloff in Bitcoin and
you're seeing it across the crypto
landscape Commodities not a big reaction
generally speaking not a big reaction to
the FED but gold look at gold gold had
been up huge today going up over that
$270 an ounce uh level and then as we
get closer to the FED meeting it starts
coming down coming down and then you see
this big move again right here around
2:00 investors saying okay we're not
getting that rate cut gold prices coming
down that I thought was a very
interesting move and again what we're
seeing from the market just really
illustrating the investor reactions to
the reality that that rate cut in March
is unlikely highly unlikely to come
because this isn't you know in uendo
this isn't rumors this is the Fed
chairman coming at you and saying at his
press conference look I don't know that
we've achieved that soft Landing we
think we've got a ways to go he's saying
I don't think it's likely that the
committee will have the confidence to
cut and Mark that's probably not the
most likely instance when you're hearing
it from the horse's mouth the market say
hey you know what that's it let's sell
these stocks let's get out of some of
these risk assets let's let's get out of
you know let's let's buy bonds because
inflation we think that rates especially
tied to that two year are going to be
lower that's what this is all about so
what we got from the statement what we
got from the press conference that's
telling us the FED is gearing up for
rate cuts the FED is still expecting to
cut rates this year you heard fed share
drone pal at his press conference say
well listen on our summary of economic
projections we're still expecting most
of the committee three rate Cuts this
year we think we're still going to lower
rates we think that's happening we think
inflation is getting back towards 2%
which is our goal but we're not
convinced yet it's it's a little bit
like a like a little kid you take him to
a roller coaster he sees the roller
coaster he's like man I want to ride
that roller coaster but I don't know let
me let me see it go one more time let me
see let me let me see it go one more
time that's the FED they say oh okay PC
inflation falling down below 3% we like
that let me see one more time okay we're
getting back down from 6% but let's see
one more time in fact you know what
let's throw up a chart here so you can
see what I'm talking about when we talk
about pce inflation uh what we're seeing
and what we have seen in terms of the
inflation rate is that inflation rate
consistently coming down that's the
fed's looking at that's what the fed's
been seeing but they want to see it
continue so let's throw a chart up here
on your screen of that inflation the PC
price index and again going back to mid2
22 you're seeing a consistent move lower
consistent move downward but what fed
Sher pal said and he was asked this
directly are you worried about inflation
picking back up he said well that's not
our biggest worry our biggest worry
right now is that inflation stays at
this level that it doesn't get back down
to 2% he said we don't want inflation to
just tap 2% we don't want it to touch 2%
we want it to get down to 2% and stay
there and we want to see more evidence
we want to see these levels continue to
move back down to 2% before we feel
comfortable with cutting rates and in
their estimation based on what we heard
from the chairman today there's not
enough evidence just yet and again this
PC chart just illustrates the way that
inflation's been moving it's moving the
way the FED wants it to but they want to
see more they want to see more they want
to see inflation continue to come back
down now he was also asked the FED
chairman about the labor market and what
could happen in terms of if they start
to see some weakness in the labor market
and let's throw a chart up here on your
screen of what we've 've been seeing
from the labor market this is the US
non-farm payrolls report aka the jobs
report which you know if you watch
Market takes uh that's actually been
picking up you're seeing the last three
months on your screen you see there uh
it looked like we were kind of starting
to move down toward that zero number in
October but instead November was higher
December was higher we have seen
consistently higher numbers on that jobs
report but the chairman did say if we do
start to see some significant
deceleration if we start to see the
labor market falling apart really start
to deteriorate that would be another
reason for them to lower rates but again
when you're looking at this chart up
here on your screen which is what the
fed's looking at there's no signs of
deterioration there's signs of strength
there's sign that the the labor market
might actually be picking up might be
gaining some strength might be gaining
ground and getting stronger and that
again is going to keep the FED on pause
keep them from cutting those rates as
fast as Wall Street might want them to
so this chart this chart right here just
illustrating the strong jobs number at
least on the headline number at least on
the headline it looks pretty good the
jobs number but the FED doesn't have a
lot of reasons based on what we heard
today from the chairman to cut those
rates and so the market not loving that
the market really wanted to see those
rate cuts the market wanted to see Fed
chare Jerome pal say yeah you know what
we're ready let's let's make it happen
they didn't say that what they said is
we want to see more evidence and so
that's going to put even more of an
emphasis on the next pieces of data
because the FED is back to being data
attendant so a a strong or a weak
inflation report a strong or a weak jobs
report any of those could move markets
significantly and that's why you're
going to want to be with us right here
on Market takes on Friday we'll be here
in two days breaking down the jobs
report for January we're going to talk
through everything jobs wages we're
going to talk through the effect on
inflation how this gets the FED moving
forward so we'll be here Friday morning
10: a.m. eastern hope you'll join us for
that last thing for more check out my
podcast wsj's take on the week we cut
through the noise to explain the major
business and financial moves major
business and financial news that moves
markets also you can make smarter
investing decisions subscribe wherever
you get your podcast that's going to do
it for us here on Market takes I am Dion
Rolan reporter at the Wall Street
Journal we hope you'll come back and do
with do it with us when we see we see
you next time